let's look in more detail at the plans
to scrap plan b covered restrictions in
england announced yesterday by mr
johnson they've been welcomed by many
including hard-hit businesses of course
desperate for a return to normal but for
others whether it's hospitals fearful of
increased pressure on already stretched
services or those who are clinically
vulnerable the relaxation is a cause of
course for anxiety well joining me now
is johnny bongo owner of bongos bingo dr
dan royal
goyle an nhs medical consultant simon
walls clinical lead at saint cecilia's
nursing home and marina gardner leg head
teacher at oxford high school very good
to see you all thank you very much
indeed for for joining us panel if i may
term you that and i want to start uh
with you with in descending order i
suppose of enthusiasm for the relaxation
so i get so that means um
your first mr bongo if i can call you
that you better explain to us first of
all what what what bongos bingo actually
is how's it different from regular bingo
bongos bingo is a it's a
it's quite hard to explain really it's
quite essentially bingo at its core um
but it's also at like a nightclub a rave
crazy prizes and a packed warehouse full
of a thousand people and partying and
playing the beautiful game of bingo okay
so
a packed warehouse um full of partying
people uh no doubt you're pleased to see
the
the restrictions ease then particularly
you were you were checking covert passes
um so we were checking covert passes in
a number of the venues we do um our
event in around 40 cities around the uk
um
the main thing for me is it's it's the
customer confidence and that's something
that we've really seen uh just since
january you know december was a really
tough time um you know it was a will it
will we won't we be able to put on our
shows
and we noticed a lot you know a lot of
sold out shows we were we were doing
them to half capacity because people
were apprehensive about coming out you
know especially around christmas and and
the rates being really high but now
certainly after new year
our sales up until
you know april we're we're at 90 they're
flying out and for me that's a positive
it's people are really busting to get
out let loose
almost try and put this kind of behind
them all right so it's as much uh about
the signals the messages it sends out as
the as the formal regulations themselves
uh marina gardner leg tell us some what
you've done today at school have you
dropped face masks because of course
you're allowed to
yes i have dermot um but i think the
face mask is only one step it would have
been nice if we were told a little bit
in advance i think with any kind of
change and particularly when you're in a
position of leadership i'm not going to
say anymore i think part of this is and
dealing with uh covid in our communities
is dealing with the requisite anxieties
and concerns of different people and the
one thing i've learned as a head is
there's always going to be somebody who
disagrees with me
if i talk about
face coverings in schools they're always
going to be people who write into me
about children's mental health as just
as there are going to be people who
celebrate if i say you can and i think
the most important thing and certainly
the thing i've learned
is that rather than it being a
government dictat i think the most
important thing for heads is to deal
with their own context
i know so many colleagues of mine in
different sectors uh and different parts
of this country who are dealing with
huge numbers of staff absence with
mental health issues with students in
year 13 and year 11 who have never taken
public exams and their commensurate
anxieties
and loads of students who are having to
miss schools because of staff absence
and i believe fundamentally that the
most important thing
is to leave different business owners
and different schools to be able to
match their own communities and i would
really have welcomed a bit of notice so
that i could go to the teacher who's
living with her 90-year-old mother and
say i am going to relieve classrooms and
i am going to say to pupils they don't
have to wear face coverings and i would
have liked a bit of time to talk that
over with her and reassure her
that's interesting what you say about it
being sprung upon you you kind of knew
it was coming but um not so imminently
simon walls from um
from the care home perspective
if and surely we've learned our lessons
by now about protecting residents of
care homes
if that is maintained are you happy then
to see
you know other parts of the world bongos
bingo and the rest of it partying on
i think we have to
accept at some point that with the
possibilities is that kobe is going to
be with us for a long long time
um and at some point we do have to come
out of
the lockdown and the things that we've
had to put into place to plan b measures
uh that were put in
i think it is like uh the lady from the
school said it's been a really quick
major reaction um to come out of it i
hope that they do go slow with other
things and consider to pull out
extremely slowly because of the strains
and the pressures on the nhs and on
ourselves in social care
we still need to protect the people that
are within these walls um i believe face
masks masks will be with us for quite
some time
certainly from where we are um and uh i
believe so probably in hospitals as well
um we have to protect the most
vulnerable and the people here suddenly
are
most vulnerable
i think everyone nodding along with that
and not just on the panel there everyone
listening and
watching uh dr goyle tell us from an nhs
perspective do you think that um this is
too far
too fast what are you seeing in terms of
these easing pressures we're told i mean
i know it's all relative it is winter
and of course the nhs is always under
pressure in winter but you know are
things calming down a bit from your
perspective
no i mean
i i think the decisions
a bit of a disaster really from the
healthcare perspective
i think it's entirely the wrong time
i think we can see very clearly that
this is not based on data science and
it's certainly not based on healthcare
provision in the uk
which is a proper low at the moment
um
you know this is the worst i've ever
seen
uh the health care provision in the uk
my colleagues up and down the country
echo that i haven't spoke to a single
colleague who said that that we're
coping or it's not the worst winter
we've ever experienced
um and you know the timing is terrible a
few more weeks
we probably could have got through it
um
you know so i'm very very disappointed
and and i think i think the public need
to ask themselves a very big question
how
much do we want good access to health
care or even decent access to health
care because at the moment we don't seem
to be getting it the record 12-hour
waits in a e which we know increases
mortality
a record on the waiting list
and i wanted to get an ambulance to
someone who said the stroke i mean i
think it's it's is it's borderline and a
bit of a okay just a bit ridiculous
i just want to ask you stay with you and
ask you a specific question because
people will want to know we are
told that of course covet cases are
dropping the pressures you described
they're primarily still being caused by
covid and and things you have to do
within hospital kobe protocols and and
social distancing i understand and also
this question we've seen now that it
seems some people in hospital
with covid are not primarily
being treated for kobe they either
acquired it when they were in hospital
or or were asymptomatic when they were
when they were admitted for something
else
yes i mean
the reason we're so overwhelmed is that
15 of the beds are taken up with covered
patients
um and and unfortunately the uk saw fit
not to increase uh healthcare capacity
at the start of the pandemic at the last
count in september
last year we were four percent less bed
capacity than we were before the
pandemic began
literally one of the only countries in
the world
not to invest in their national health
service to the degree that was needed
and we bear in mind derma every time
we've had to lock down it's because the
nhs has has been full or reaching
capacity
and yet still we haven't invested in it
so so there's no surprise 15 percent of
our occupancy to covered um the nhs
england is nine percent over safe
occupancy limits at the moment
so very interesting
yeah i'm even fascinating to get that
insight doctor goal i want to talk um
about um well
money now i suppose with you johnny
bongo
does this have to be this direction of
travel now does it have to be
irreversible for you because you've been
dealing with
shutting opening half opening for what
18 months now
yeah i think um you know the nightlife
industry
for the last two years have suffered so
so it's been so tough and
you know 2022 we need it we need a clear
run and you know we need to continue on
just as normal you know we have been
we've been lucky that we've built up a
a business that's seen it through and
but there's been so many people that
haven't in the hospitality industry been
able to survive and
you know
we just need to
move on and in my opinion
simon walter i just want to go back to
covet infections because uh i saw you
agreeing with dr goyle there um have you
had
any omicron occurring in the home
sadly we have derma and i know a lot of
care homes across the
country
i've also had a lockdown we're still in
lockdown at this minute in time due to
an outbreak within the care home
um so we're at this minute in time we
have eight beds that are usually used
for people that can relieve the pressure
on the nhs
so obviously that's increasing the
pressure on on my nhs colleague
to mean that they're actually having
people in their beds that are actually
medically fit for discharge but they're
unable to come into the nursing homes or
the care homes because they're locked
down because of omicron now it has been
reduced to 14 days from 28 which was a a
positive in some ways
um but also the different things like
the swapping on the fifth and sixth day
you can go back to work there's still a
15 to 20
chance that you can still spread omicron
if you come back to work at that time
and in a small company if you lose two
or more staff that puts you under even
more pressure and then increases more
more pressure on the nhs and the risk
again of another lockdown
marina gardner-legge
tell me this and it's some a version of
the same question i put to johnny bongo
there about direction of travel here in
terms of what we were discussing earlier
about um the certainty that that you
need that your staff need that the
parents need and of course at the
students need and particularly this
question
about many of them sitting exams for for
the first time
for two years do you need to know pretty
much now that they are going to go ahead
i think i think that's really hard
actually for that to happen but i think
i'd like to pick up if i made them at an
earlier point we talked about the nhs
and we talked about its capacity
and we need at some point to talk about
the epidemic of mental health issues
that we are seeing in young people the
inability of the child and mental health
services that are cracking at the scenes
they are desperate to help but they are
under-resourced
desperately under-resourced and schools
are dealing with the most incredible
anxiety not just in their young people
but also in their parents and then again
in the students now we do what we can we
know that the most important thing for
children's mental health is to be in
school and to be with their peers that's
where their mental health issues and
idea of self-esteem comes from so we are
doing our very best with that but we
also need this resource behind us
otherwise this generation are not just
going to catch covid but they're also
going to be scarred
terribly and irrevocably if they don't
get the support they need from
specialists i'm just going to go to dr
goyle on that because i saw you
nodding along there and of course this
is the issue with
the whole of covid19 it's not just about
the infections it's all these unwanted
by-products in so many areas and and in
particular as uh marina was just saying
there this this issue of the mental
health impact the nhs is going to be
dealing with that for years to come one
imagines
absolutely derma i mean the the mental
health provision
is shameful um i mean we are hugely
under resourced understaffed on the
front line but that you know what what
particularly the child mental health
services have to deal with you know it
pales into the significance it's so bad
um and we should be ashamed as a nation
that we've allowed it to slip that far
um we deal with it every day people are
anxious
but derma i think we've come to the
point where you're less anxious if you
have good leadership
and if you are showing people that we're
in control we will escalate restrictions
and and protections when there's a surge
of infections we will release them when
there's not we will put mitigations in
schools we'll put ventilation systems
and venues
you take control of the situation and
demonstrate to the people but but i'm
sorry i flailing about leadership that
that really can't get a handle on it is
going to increase everybody's anxieties
um covert is here we have to face it and
i think you know
we do have to protect the people while
you're clearly showing great leadership
in your own field sir dr goyle johnny
bongo simon walls marina gardiner leg
thank you all very very much indeed i'm
afraid we're out of time and when when
this is finally all behind us i think we
all need a good night out at
bongos bingo don't you johnny i'm sure
you'll be keen to accommodate us see you
all there